各位同学好，咱们上课。
今天是咱们蛇年第一课啊，所以首先给大家拜个年，祝大家蛇年大吉。
嗯，咱们今年上课已经是第五年了啊，刚才上课之前还在说这棵小草啊，小树还是小草吧，已经开始挡镜头了，是吧？
嗯，我们5年前第一次录课的时候，这棵草就在咱们的讲桌上，现在已经长这么高了。
咱还是修剪一下吧，难道还是怎么着，反正就是。
还是不太忍心把他请出去，毕竟也是陪伴我们成长啊。
简单总结一下吧，咱们去年的课程啊，因为咱们的班级啊其实分两类同学，一类是主公长剧和电影。
你可以理解是传统影视的班，咱们早期这样的同学比较多。
但是从前年和去年，特别是去年开始呢。
由于短剧的崛起，所以咱咱们短剧班的同学呢呃比长句班的同学要多了。
呃，这也正常啊，因为短剧毕竟市场也比长剧大，而且又是新兴起的市场，新兴起的市场有个什么好处呢？对小白比较友好。由于咱们很多同学呢可能呃创作基础没有那么强，经验也不太丰富。所以说以短剧为突破口也是挺好的啊。所以咱们去年着重给短剧班的同学。
接的戏比较多啊，接的剧本订单比较多。
然后今年呢也是开年，我们就跟小说平台开始合作啊，嗯把一些小说版权改成短剧。所以说短剧的市场还是在持续高温啊，持续高温。然后长剧呢今年也迎来了好消息啊，也就是说传统影视也迎来了好消息，开年就有重磅炸弹，哪吒。
就好。
这也是咱们今天这节课的主题，给大家讲讲哪吒啊，哪吒啊带起的整个春节档当然也是呃不光是哪吒创纪录了啊，现在登陆影史第一，这个春节档也是影史春节档最热的一个春节档啊。
所以说。
给我们传统影视也带来了信心。咱们衷心的希望，今年不管是电影长剧、短剧，希望整个内容市场都能红火啊，给我们创作者更多的创作空间。
所以今天呢咱们就哪吒啊学习一下相关的一些知识啊，我们来再来复习和强化一下啊。
嗯。
我今天嗓子有点不好，我讲话就轻一点啊，流感流感还没好，最近流感蛮严重的。
希望同学们都保持身体健康啊。
哪吒最近同学们啊问的问题最多的第一个当然是哪吒为什么有这么高的票房是吧？很多人跟我探讨过啊。
其实坦白说，同学们。
虽然哪吒是大年初一上映的。
但是其实在。
过年前半个月吧。
我们。
私底下啊已经预测过。
哪吒会是春节档的票房冠军。
而且是。
几乎没有争议啊几乎没有争议。当时内部啊，或者是说人家出品方保50争70。当然了，人家出品方不可能在内部公司的墙上写着哪吒2保50争70，对吧？让人拍了传出去也挺难看的。
但是通过交流啊，我能感受到的数字是非常明确的。
五十是稳的，七十是要冲的。
但是现在。
奔10百去了是吧？至少九十几吧，说明其实。
市场还是可以有一些预判的啊，我甚至当时都建议我身边炒股人可以买点光线的股票。
不知道这违不违规啊，这算不算违规，咱也不清楚啊，咱也不炒股不研究这个问题。那我们就说哪吒这个票房为什么如此稳稳的就夺魁了呢？
我认为啊呃粗略的说三方面原因吧。
第一个本身片子质量确实过硬。
对吧人家饺子导演确实花了很多的心思，整个团队花了很多的精力。
呃，很多的劳动去做这个。
工作。
确实是。
过硬也很不容易的一个大的一个工程。
质量肯定是第一位的啊，所以说第一个原因一定是质量本身好。
第二个原因呢，就是我们刚才说的大盘也好，就这个春节档是。
超乎寻常的热。
对吧因为本来啊咱们坦白说，咱们刚才说了啊，从课程我们就能看出来。
去年啊报短剧的同学比报长剧班的同学，就是说想学习短剧写作的比想学传统的长剧和电影写作的同学要多很多。
为啥呢？大家对传统市场没有信心了，所以说这个春节档如此大爆啊，其实是有点出人意料的。所以说大盘好，那整个大家都好嘛。
即便是骂声一片的片子，那不也好几亿嘛，对吧？有些人说哎呀这个大烂片，你看才几亿票房，几亿票房在几年前挺不错的呢，是不是？
所以说大盘好啊，是第二个原因。
第三个原因啊就是。
说的难听一点，用网上的话哈呃网友的话不是我的话啊。
全靠同行衬托啊，确实是竞争对手集体扑街，也不知道怎么回事儿。让我想起来当年啊沈腾玛丽。
或者是开心麻花横空出世的那个电影呃，夏洛特烦恼。其实那个档期厮杀也很激烈了，就是因为集体扑街啊，导致那个电影脱颖而出了。不相信的同学可以查一查当时和夏洛特烦恼同档期的是哪些片子，这是哪吒这个电影。
横空出世的第三个原因吧。当然了，这只是粗略的估计。至于故事怎么好啊，咱们这节课可以挑几个重点给大家讲一讲。
呃，另外咱们同学问我的第二个问题，也是网上我也经常刷到的一个问题啊。
我们也聊一下吧，这个问题也令我挺无语。
就同学问我说。
饺子导演是不是特别苦？
特别穷困是吧？然后混的不好，是不是在圈子里面还受人排挤，因为他不是科班出身。
甚至还举例子说，你看郭凡导演不就是这样吗？
开出了那么优秀的流浪地球，但是呢也好像也不得什么奖，跟主流圈子好像也被排挤，不来往怎么。
这个问题我我也解答一下，因为我还挺有资格解答的，因为我也不是传统的影视学校。
我也不是中西北电啊、上戏啊、中传啊、军逸啊这些学校毕业的。
我是上海交通大学毕业的。
有没有说这种排挤呢？我可以负责任的告诉大家呃，没有。
啊，没有。
呃，首先。
我们说同一个学校的校友之间抱团取暖一定是有的，但这是正常现象。
抱团取暖不代表排挤别人，对吧？你像饺子导演或者是郭方导演这么有才华，这么有能力的人，谁会排挤他？
对吧难道说过文导演或者是饺子导演想做一个项目，人家一看他不是北电的，就不给他投资了，或者是就给他穿小鞋嘛？不至于好吧，所以说。
同学们不要看到一个人突然，其实饺子导演人家也不算突然出来吧，对吧？人家也是做了很多年工作了，咱们的网友啊，或者是那个那个民众啊。
是愿意给他加戏的，特别愿意加苦情戏啊，就说这个导演多么多么可怜是吗？呃，我看还有什么说饺子导演曾经在家啃老三年啊，穷困潦倒。
能在家啃老三年，我觉得肯定不是穷困潦倒呀。你让我在家啃老三个月，我妈就给我打出来了，是吧？所以说大家不要给他加苦情戏啊，这样不好。
呃，虽然我也知道就是就是。
你看之前那个那个那个那个嗯演员呃张松文老师也是突然爆火然后打家来就给他加了很多苦情戏，说他什么住地下室。
哎呦吃不上饿的，吃不上饭，到菜市场捡菜叶子，哎呀，这都有点过于对吧？加了这么多苦情戏。
结果呢等过一段时间发现啊这个演员好像过得不错，然后又开始好像又要又要翻车踏黄的意思就出来了啊。
就是我觉得没有必要啊没有必要，就是我们就看作品啊。
所以说大家不用担心饺子导演呃被排挤或者是没项目啊，我觉得不至于，对吧？因为你只要有能力啊，大家都是愿意合作的啊，咱们就不说这些。
题外话了啊，尽快的说哪吒这部电影我们能学到什么东西。因为咱们毕竟还是要自己去。
渣咋写。
哪吒啊这部电影。
我们说首先这个故事啊是一个传统的大IP。
传统大IP。
在咱们之前课程上讲过啊，最大的IP其实是西游系列啊，哪吒你可以理解西游里面也有封神里面也有啊，所以说绝对算是响当当的大IP。
咱们国家啊开发过的最大的古典IP就是西游系列啊，第二是三国系列。所以说这个片子成功啊有方方面面的因素。
我们这节课呢就从故事角度去探讨一下。
没看过的同学可以去看一下。
但是也不用过分担心啊，我不会给你剧透很多呃致命的东西。
首先我们说这个故事啊。
是一个标准的商业片。
我们能这么说吧。
获得了如此巨大的商业成功，如果都还在那哎呀，老师你说他是商业片是侮辱饺子蛋，大可不必是吧？就是商业篇嘛，就是商业篇不是贬义词呀，多好的商业片啊。
百亿票房还不是商业片，那啥是商鱼？
它里面有很多啊重要的商业元素啊，首先我们从人物角度来。
这个主角从哪吒一的时候，咱们就讲过这个角色我们说叫典型的。
两面人哪吒是中国影史。
票房最高的电影主角是两面人。
到底是么？
还是先。
两面人也不是贬义词啊，都是中性词。我们说身份危机啊，来世界影史票房最高的电影是什么？阿凡达。
阿凡纳的主角。
你到底是地球人还是纳米星人？你给我说清楚。
是不是也是两面？
标准的啊商业设定主角是两面人。然后呢，我们有之前又说过。
主角要有系统，但是在民间。
也就是说他不是个凡人。
但是呢在凡间压在凡间了，我们说诶。
哪吒呃李靖陈塘官李靖陈塘官李靖虽然他贵为将军，但是在封神体系里面就是个凡人。
对不对？
所以哪吒出生在凡人家庭，但是他有血统，他是魔玩降生。来这样的主角，同学们还能想到哪些？
首当其冲，英国第一畅销书哈利波特。
有血统，但是在民间啊。
对不对？
孙悟空就不用说了，补天神石是吧？沦落花果山。
然后还有什么？
我们说大票房呢有血统在民间的。
还能想到什么？同学们。
熊猫大侠。
是吧这都是。
一个熊猫。
在鸭子压。
我们说。
这也是一个很重要的商业元素。
再还有什么啊？
这个片子里面还有一个标准的。
商业元素，我们说叫主角和对手是两生花，一颗枝上的两朵花。
主角与对手啊。
其实是同样的人。
第一步的对手。
除了申公豹以外，就是敖丙吧。
第二部里边。
我们的主角哪吒跟敖丙直接什么？
合体啦。
这都不用两生花了，一朵花里了。
而且套用两生花这个概念套了多狠，他俩在什么里面出生的？
莲花呀。
明白吧？
一颗枝上的两朵花，这是去标准的设定方式。
当然了，他在这一季里面。
在第二部里面，他跟敖丙已经从对手变为了队友。
并合体了。
一踢两魂。
那么他的另外一个对手。
申公豹。
你觉得申公豹跟。
哪吒的关系不是两生花。
不是同样的人吗？申公豹跟哪吒不是同样的人吗？
哪吒是个魔。
非要成仙，但是压不住自己的魔性。神公豹呢他是个妖，想要成仙，但是压不住自己的妖性，依然是仙界的另类。
申公豹跟哪吒的关系也是镜子里面的你和我。
而且。
这种设定方式让我们又想到什么？
蜘蛛侠。
同学们回忆一下蜘蛛侠的那几步。
蜘蛛侠的对手是谁？张一博是和他儿子，那不就是他妈镜子里面的另外一个自己吗？那俩人。
对不对？这个结构非常像。所以说啊。
商业篇啊，特别是成功的商业篇，里面有很多重要的商业元素是需要我们去学习和运用的。
但是没有人这个世界上没有一个人会指着哪吒和。
蜘蛛侠或者指着哪吒和哈利波特说，这两个片子互相雷同和抄袭，不会的。
明白我意思吧？。
那么。
我们今天需要来学习一下哪吒这种故事类型。
为什么会如此获得欢迎啊？刚才说的是商业元素，我们说哪吒这个故事它是什么类型？哪吒这个故事是属于标准的。
这是一个大类啊。
也就是说。
在一个体制里面，在一个体系里面。
哪吒这个故事非常明确的，这个世界上有仙有妖，有魔，有人。
他是一个体系。
然后大家通过什么样的方式能够进到这个体制，能够进到这个制度，对吧？然后这个制度是怎么。
控制另外的控制这个平衡。
他有哪些善与恶，就这种主题或者是这种大类的故事。
爆款频出。
我之前讲过啊，我之前在直播的时候讲过，我说你如果想写一个能得奖口碑好的。
可以考虑这种。
但凡涉及阶层或者制度或者体系。
这片子很容易。
好口碑，凤俊浩导演那个片子啊，寄生虫。
典型吧。
对不对？
不对抗呀。
系抗。
再加上。
影史排评分经常排名第一的片子，肖申克的救赎。
一个监狱体系。
是吧有典狱长，有浴霸，有平民，他们是怎么哎一个体系，一个制度。
我们说这种片子啊。
嗯，我们这节课着重的讲一下。
那首先我们回顾一下。
故事都有哪些大的类型？
制度对抗是里面的一个小的类型。
我们这节课回顾一下。
首先，故事分5个大类啊分5个大类。
第一个。
叫角色，或者我们叫人物吧。
叫人物的成长。
第一个大类叫人物的成长。第二个大类叫目标的追寻。
第三个大类叫困境的摆脱。
第四个大类叫愿望的实现，或者叫梦幻的实现啊。第五个大类叫解密啊。我们说世界上所有的故事你可以笼统的大体的基本上分为这五类，或者是说吸引人的故事。
商业的故事分为这五类。
第一类叫关于人物的成长。
因为故事还是要以人为本。
故事发明就是为了人与人之间增增强沟通效率的。
所以说。
我们是希望自己改变，希望自己成长。
这是第一类。
关于人物成长。
人物成长的故事，当然里面也有细分啊。
也有戏分。
有。
普通人遇到。
也有大人物困在小。
小事儿。
是吧也有呢。
讲亲密关系的。
讲两个。
主角互相成为彼此。
就是我们俗称的爱情片啊或者友情片。
我们说爱情片友情片。
也是关于人物成长的，为什么呢？因为他会成长为彼此。
这节课我们就不展开来说了啊。
第二类故事目标的追寻对吧？追寻一个什么样的目标，达成一个什么样的目的。
也是很多故事的啊主线。
故事的主线。
然后第三类呢是困境。
人啊除了追寻目标，追寻理想之外，那总归也有遇到困难的时候。
遇到困难的时候，那么。
当然，困难有很多种有。
人生的困难，比如说。
生老病死啊。
不幸呀，对吧？遇到这种困难。我们说这是一种呃小类型，比如说内布拉斯加萨利对吧？这种电影，然后也有遇到意外的麻烦，对吧？记不记得我们以前讲过。
就猫咪。
旧猫咪里面有这种故事叫麻烦家伙。我们说那就是一个家伙突然遇到了麻烦，我们说那叫意外啊，遇到一个意外的麻烦，这也是一种故事类型。
然后第三种就是我们说的。
制度体系。
也就是说。
在故事的五个大类当中。
制度对抗属于困境故事的。
三个当中的一个。
我先把下面一点说完啊，梦幻也分两种，一种属于美梦，一种属于噩梦。因为人都会做梦。还有一种说法说。
电影就什么？
故事就是梦是吧？可以这么理解啊，那么梦就分两种，美梦和噩梦。
所以说关于梦幻的故事。
也是一个大类，美梦很简单。
我突然穿越了。
我突然有种某种超能力了，金手指了，夏洛特烦恼，对吧？你好，李焕英，这都是于穿越的。
重生的。
还有。
突然有种某种超能力的，是吧？
突然有这个神灵降临保帮助我的奇魂是吧？
这种故事当然有噩梦闹鬼了。
恐龙复活了是吧？噩梦，然后最后一种是解密类的。
有个谜题对吧？我们理解的探案片、悬疑片都属于这一类。因为一旦有个谜题，这种故事也往往很吸引人。
这就是我们说的故事的五大类啊。
有同学可能好奇跟。
救猫咪的故事的呃商业片的10个类型片有什么区别啊？
首先我们说一下。
救猫咪的。
商业片10个类型。
那是。
人家总结。
人施耐德总。
它适用于好莱坞体系啊，好莱坞体系你可以理解。
他还是比较西方思维的。
而且是从整个影片的角。
我们提出的故事的五个大类呢，是从创作的角度。
或者是从讲故事。
从编剧的角度。
因为我们在构思一个故事的时候啊。
我们脑子里面要想这个故事的主要的发展路径，它的主要的对抗，他角色走的。
故事这个这个线路我们才能往上装事件。那我们在构思这件事情的时候，我们在构思这个线索的时候，我们总要有个依托呀。
这时候我们就用这5个类型来。
归类自整理自己的故事。我这个故事它主要是什么？
当然了，我也曾经说过好的商业故事，它往往可以跨两个类型。
他可以兼顾两个。
也就是说他把两类故事的重点。因为我们坦白说一个完整的故事，你说里面有没有人物成长一定有嘛？这个人有没有目标也有嘛？
有没有困难，也有嘛。
梦幻有没有不一定对吧？有解密有没有，多多少少也可能有一点，总归有点悬念了。
对吧你就像哪吒里面有没有解密？
他爸妈到底谁咋的？
也有这个悬念吧。
但是他没有根据这条线去探究。
他没有根据这条线去写剧情，去慢慢探究他爸妈到底是谁渣了第一层误会，第二层误会，第三层误会好像要解开了，发现还是个误会。
没有根据这条线去写，所以我们不能说哪吒是解密类型的故事。
甚至他都没有用这个。
他都没有根据这个形去展开。
明白这个意思吧？
所以说。
判断一个故事是什么类型，你得自己去判断它根据什么类型展开主线。
而不是他还有什么元素。
我们说一个故事大概率还有1234，这四个元素基本都会有梦幻有没有不一定。所以说哪吒这个故事我们。
非常明确的把它放在制度对抗这个类型。
为什么呢？因为制度类型对抗这个。
故事类型我们今天展开说给大家回顾一下。
他的要点。
他的要点啊。
首先。
他要有一个。
三个元素。
首先它要有一个环境。
体制。
然后要有一个。
觉醒者。
然后会有他的。
医生宇。
也就是说，制度对抗。
类型的故事有着。
三个元素。
环境体制刚才我们说了。
故事非常明确，这个世界上分为西安。
妖魔人。
然后呢，有个晋升体系，你得修炼多少年？
当然也有那个捷径，你可以吃什么丹是吧？就可以获取别人的修炼成果。
然后呢，这么一个。
成为那个仙之后呢，位列先斑它有个什么样的好处？
不好意思啊，一直咳嗽。
也就是说会有一个环境体制。然后呢，一个觉醒者一般来说就是咱们的主角了，哪吒。当然在这部戏里面，我们说另外一个非常出彩的角色是谁呀？
申公报。
诶，为什么申公豹从反派或者是从我们说故事当中的对手或者反派不一定指的是坏人。
指的是什么来着？回顾一下与主角行动线相冲的人，也就是说阻碍主角主行动线的人一律成为反派。那么申公暴是标准的反派。
特别是在哪吒一里面，在哪吒二里面申公暴教。
叫什么？
叫第一反派。我们说故事有两个反派。
在故事终点之前在故事终点之前。
有一个反派，终点之后有二第二个反派，第一反派不只是不是指最重要的那个反派啊，是第一个。然后后面第二个反派才是最重要。
我们说一般故事终点之前一个反派。
或者是要假反派吧，假对手。
故事终点之后是针对手。
申公豹依然是对手的角色，但申但有我们又觉得申公豹为何如此可爱？
对吧虽然他是个对手，但为什么如此可爱？是因为申公豹在这个故事里面也是觉醒者。
他也看透了。
他也看透这个。
环境体制了。
然后呢，第三个元素就是要有牺牲和成长。因为这个环境体制形成，它不是一朝一夕的呀。
你要跟他对抗，你觉醒了不就是要对抗吗？哪吒牺牲成长，那显然很明显是吧？差点家破人亡，自己差点死了不说是吧？他妈也死。
显然是有牺牲的。至于成长呢，我们说哪吒一定是有成长，因为他觉醒。
但是你说哪吒属不属于人物成长类型的故事呢？
还是那句话，一个故事里面有人物成长，不代表它是人物成长类型的故事。因为任何故事里面几乎都有人物成长。分类的时候，我们的依据是它有没有基于人物成长展开趋势。
也就是说。
我们哪吒的这个觉醒，我们又没有根据这条线索把它铺开。
就好像我说解密，你说有没有解密啊，申波豹到底叛没叛变，他去哪儿了？
然后你陈塘关到底怎么回事，谁杀的？
确实是个悬疑，确实有秘密。但这个故事它类型不是解密，因为我们没有根据解密展开第一个线索，第二个线索，第三个线索又是误导，我们又重新整理没有。
人物成长也是人物成长类型的故事。我们要根据人物成长去。
我的第一次成长第一次被触动，第二次被触动，第三次被触动是吧？第四次我自第四次又有误会了，我又觉得他还是假的是吧？慢慢去成长。
这个故事。
他显然是围绕这件事情来讲。
好吧。
我们说因为。
这三个元素。
我们就来想一想。
这种类型的故事是不是甲片频出啊？
刚才说过。
赢时排第一的肖申克雷救赎来环境体质。
美国的这个监狱黑暗的系统。
显然是个环境体制，觉醒者来了一个无罪的人，还是个银行家，还是个高级知识分子安y。
对吧然后呢，他为了对抗这个。
机制。
是不是也牺牲也成长？
标准的环境体制的片子，其实大家讲的最多的还是肥野风云苑。
对吧疯人医院这个体系。
你作为里面唯一一个不封的人，你咋个你咋个弄嘛？
当然了，去年的拉片课，咱们去年带着大家看了几十部电影，对吧？去年的拉片课，我给大家讲的环境体制类型的电影，最典型的是什么？
幸福终点。
幸福终点站讲的是什么故事呢？
汤姆汉克斯。
男主角。
作为一个东方人。
实际上是西亚东欧那边的啊斯坦。
什么斯塔。
飞到美国去。
飞到美国去干什么？追星找一个歌星签名，当然是完成了他爸爸的遗愿啊，后面再解密。
显然是一个东方人是去西方追求西方的精神文化。
然后在飞飞行的过程中。
他的国家。
问题了叛变了呃，就出叛乱了。
国家就消失了，他的护照作废了，所以一落地，他就成了。
没有身份的人，他出不了机场，他就被困在了机场。你看困在了西方体制里面。
西方这个死板的制度。
对吧认为你没有国家了，你这我你国家跟我不建交了。
是吧我你这个护照作废了。
你现在走不了也出不去，你就困在机场，不知道咋办。
他当然是一个觉醒者呀，他是那里唯一一个东方人，而连英文都不会说。然后他利用自己勤劳的双手，东方智慧在那个机场里活了下来，而且还谈上了恋爱。
然后最后逃逃出了这个体系。
也是跟飞岳丰人院一样。
水当然也做出了牺牲和成长，牺牲了自己的爱情。
牺牲了自己的梦想。我们说这些都是标准的啊。
大家都可以把这些片子再去给我看一看，好不好？
好吧，刚才说过了啊，肖申克的救赎。
飞跃疯人院幸福终点站。当然还有死亡飞车疯狂动物城。
同学们给我看一下疯狂动物城。
疯狂动城大家都看过吧。
哪吒说，这个世界上有。
仙魔人妖。
疯狂动物说成说这个世界上有肉食动物、草食动物。
对吧。
然后呢，我们的主角觉醒者呢，哪吒是生而为魔，非要当先。
疯狂动物城的主角兔子是生来是个兔子，非要当警察。
然后呢，对抗这个体制，对抗这个制度。
最后。
发现哪吒发现他妈去他妈的体制，去他那么时间那些道貌岸然的。
吸烟原来是最坏。
那些慈眉善目的大头娃娃，原来是最邪恶。
疯狂动物城呢？
那兔子发现。
那个说话细声细语，夹子音的小绵羊是他妈最坏的。
草食动物才是最心狠手辣的。
对吧统治这个世界的所谓的善良的草食动物才是。
最坏的呢另外。
再说一下。
这类片子。
它的一般结构，刚才讲到终点啊，我们说一个故事最重要的就是它中间这个大转转折啊，中间这个大的。
这类故事的转折一般是什么呢？
一般是故事的前半段。
我们的。
融入体系，我们的主角要拼命的融入体系。
然后故事的后半段叫。
破坏体系。
这是这类故事的中间的大转折。你一旦会写这个中间的这个大转折，你这个故事基本上在大结构上就不会拉胯。
我们说哪吒在故事的前半段。
邪魔妖人这个体系里面他要干什么？
考编制。
考试吗？三次考试。
笔试面试进体制。
对吧我们哪吒拼命的要融入这个体系。
然后后半段呢去他妈的体系，我干死他。
干死这个体系。
肖申克的救赎。
安迪前半段要匙有要干什么？
要融入这个监狱。
运用自己的。
金融知识帮着典狱长洗黑钱。
运用自己的金融知识，帮着狱警们避税。
对吧然后运用自己的手工呀，好人缘啊，开始交朋友。
是吧甚至会借力打力借这个借力打力报复那些欺负他的人。
融入这个体系。
但是故事终点，他发现融入这个体系是没有尽头的。
这里太邪恶了，我要逃出这个体系，所以他后半段开始越狱。
记不记得肖顺哥就熟。
死亡飞车也是呀，前半段。
发现这个监狱在搞地下赌博，我要成为冠军。后半段去他妈的冠军，我是利用这个比赛要逃出去。
懂了吧。
福雪丰如艳也是呀。
前半段装疯，后半段逃跑。
对不对？
所以说。
所有制这个。
制度对抗类型的故事啊。
中间的大转折。
前半段你就写这个主角怎么样去融入这个体系，甚至慢慢如鱼得水。但是在终点触发一下，我混如鱼得水干什么？
本身就是错的。
然后再去破坏这个体系。
哪吒标准的。所以说。
从这个角度你去看哪吒这个故事毫无争议，是五个大类当中的困境，困境三个小类当中的制度。
那讲到这里。
其实同学们也可以。
理解。
为什么这个片子有这么大？
我们说一个。
出生。
很不好的人。
拼命的想。
进入。
体制。
后来发现。
我们说这样的故事经常在。
现实中社会中上演。
所以说引发了很多的共鸣。
引发了很多的公鸣，甚至。
我看同档的另外一个电影像。
那个那个。
交融行动啊好像成绩不是很理想。
呃，也很不服。其实严格来说啊。
哪吒作为一个动漫啊动画片。
确实。
本来不太是市场最主流。
因为动画片啊一直就不太是市场最主。
因为他是个神话故事，是吧？
但是我看到有一个评论特别有意思。我们说哪吒讲的故事。
和蛟龙行行动讲的故事。
到底谁写诗，谁神话？
也不好。
所以说咱们这节课啊。
就是给大家。
利用哪吒这个电影，首先我们也致敬一下。
这个。
电影的制作团队以及饺子导演。
另外呢我们也趁机学习回顾。
巩固一些我们自己的。
知识点啊，希望同学们都能。
加入创作，借着哪吒给咱们带来的这个。
呃，信心带来的这个春风啊，蛇年的第一股春风，希望我们行业今年呃更好一些。我们的大家的创作机会更多一些，好吧，下课。